شركه تسلا مخترقه تسريب مئه جيجا بايت من
بياناتها السريه بينها 23 الف ملف مع
شكاون وردتها بين عامي 2015 و 2022
الاف الشكاوى تتعلق بالسلامه ابرزها نظام
سلامه الطيار الالي فيما وصلتها 4000 شكوى
حول مشكلات التسريع الذاتي والتوقفات
المفاجئه
اما التقارير عن الحوادث فبلغت اكثر من
الف تقريرا معظمها في الولايات المتحده
وشملت التسريبات تفاصيل حول الانتاج
والموظفين ومعلومات مصرفيه للعملاء فضلا
عن تعليمات بنقل المعلومات للعملاء شفهيا
دون تسجيلها
رد تسلا جاء سريعا قائله ان موظفا سابقا
ساخطا استخدم وظيفته كفني لسرقه المعلومات
وستقاضيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات